I don't know why Magnus is still silent
because my read of the situation was
that there was some sort of NDA or
there's some information that chess.com
had that was like they could not release
and so my read of it was Magnus was
essentially saying the same thing
chess.com said where like I can't say
anything about it because of whatever
whatnot but then chess.com releases what
I perceive to be the stuff that they
could not talk about anyway and Magnus
still isn't saying anything so I don't
really understand why Magnus has not
said anything further it could be legal
implications of accusing somebody of
cheating uh over the board that could be
like lawsuits that he just doesn't want
the headaches he just wants to focus on
the game and have fun playing the game
and not get bogged down into lawyers and
all that kind of yeah it's definitely
possible but Magnus could also take the
other route and just say well he cheated
online in 100 games like I'm not gonna
play against a cheater that's very easy
to say that's factual it's proven and
that doesn't have to go into the
speculation over the board so I I find
it a little bit odd that Magnus hasn't
said anything further at the same time
it's also kind of peculiar because
magnus's reputation is also kind of in
in tatters in a sense like a lot of
people are not happy with him for what
he's done uh but still he goes and plays
this tournament in this European Club
Cup Tournament and he's just gaining
like 10 points as though nothing has
happened so I I mean I I don't I don't I
don't really know where magnus's head is
at because like if I was in that
situation and everyone's coming after me
for making such an accusation I don't
think there's any way I'd be I would be
able to play chess anywhere near the
level that Magnus is playing at so the
whole situation is yeah it's very
strange yeah I wonder where his mind is
at that he's able to play at that level